[Music]
Bachelorette star Robbie Hayes weighs in
on that Luke Pell controversy it's a
tough situation he's in you know cuz he
wasn't picked and now he's gonna deal
with all the backlash from Robbie hit up
the Tortuga Music Festival in Fort
Lauderdale Florida where we got his take
on claims that Luke tried to cast women
on The Bachelor that he was already
dating before producers made a
last-minute switch and picnic vile
instead kind of sounds gonna lose lose
situation became but Luke's great guy I
like a lot I hope for him that he's
dealing with it appropriately so what
does he make of Nick and Vanessa's
relationship is it a sham I hope for
Nick sake that it's real cuz he's been
down this road nine times we're gonna
find out here soon I think and I'm not
gonna say I think it's real but I'm not
so I'm not gonna call it fakes I'm sure
there's feelings there
as for Robbie's own future with the
franchise he hints we just might see him
in paradise I have filled out paperwork
I'm gonna do some of the testing that we
had to go through before we do it but in
the end it will be a decision that I'll
have to sit down with my family and me
you